Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
I'm very appreciative of that.
Wes and I used to work together.
He was an educator with the program that I fly for.
We've stayed in touch a little bit over the years, mostly when hot topics come up in the
EMS field and people are arguing online.
We tend to send things to one another.
We decided to have a quick chat on the show today, just about some general topics of discussion,
more clinical based.
We'll just dive into this.
I'm just going to hit Wes with some provocative questions and we'll see where it takes us.
The first one is, which is better for RSI, a tomodate or ketamine?
Why is it ketamine?
I'll give you my answer to this.
I like ketamine.
Here's why I'm a proponent of ketamine and what I do, whether ambulance, direct patient
care, or an air medical, or in some of our austere environments.
We've also chatted about working overseas and stuff like that.
I'm very familiar with ketamine.
I use ketamine for a lot of different things.
I'm very familiar with it at different drug dosages, familiar with its effects.
I'm familiar with the concentration we carry on our ambulance.
I'm kind of a clinical minimalist when it comes to medications, but what I do like out
of my medications is I like to be able to use it for a variety of things.
If we carry a medication, I want it to either be super important or have a lot of variety.
I've worked for services that carry three different benzos, but I love carrying a medication
that's like, hey man, we can use this for five different things.
That's ketamine for me.
I fully believe in our environment, familiarity with the medication is something that's not
talked about, but it aids in things.
That's why I like ketamine.
Having said that, obviously the research that's come out has shown that ketamine's human
dynamic profile isn't what we thought it was.
All the research of the last five years has shown that ketamine is not the hemodynamic
superhero that some of the people thought it was.
It's also shown that a comedy is not the villain that people thought it was, but having said
all that, it doesn't necessarily make ketamine a villain or a comedy a hero either.
The majority of RSI goes back to what you do outside of those meds, whether it be resuscitation,
correctly identifying who can benefit from it.
We talked about dose adjustment.
I'm a huge advocate for adjusting dosages based on numerous things.
I think a lot of that matters more than just which sedation you necessarily pick.
For sure.
I agree with that.
I think in the time that I've been working in critical care, we've transitioned to just
using ketamine preferentially for everything.
It's been touted as a very safe drug with minimal hemodynamic effects.
It's been interesting to see the conversation in the last year or so where that's being
second guessed.
But you're right that I think the focus will eventually land on the things we're doing
before we give the medications.
I assume it's the same where you work, but when you were still here flying with us, we
had a pretty strong emphasis on the resuscitation phase, particularly in airway management,
resuscitate before you push drugs, before you decide to intubate, as part of that decision,
I guess.
I guess I don't totally have a good idea of how prevalent that is in other services or
in other areas outside of the critical care or flight sphere.
My impression is that it is gaining traction.
I think people are starting to notice that.
Yeah.
I see it a lot around here.
In Texas, it's a medically aggressive state pre-hospital.
I think for the most part, it's really made its way here in Texas.
Scott Weingart coined the term hot killers.
I hear that every time I turn a corner.
I think for the most part, at least where I work, you hear people more concerned with
the hemodynamics and the hypoxia and the pre-innovation killers.
I think we're going to eventually approach a phase where those aren't the patients that
are catching us off guard with peri-innovation hypotension or hypoxia.
We have the group of people that we know are physiologically tough right now.
We have the people that are physiologically very safe.
There's a sliver of gray area in the middle to where they're not physiologically strong,
but maybe their numbers aren't, you know, cystog-blow 90 or shock index wise.
Once we do form RSI, DSI, boom, they drop.
I think that little sliver, the future of education for EMS critical care or pre-hospital
critical care like what we work in, that's where we're going.
We end up having to capture of needing to optimize or pre-recess to take those patients
prior to intubation.
Yeah.
No, that totally makes sense.
I like the point you made about preferring ketamine for its many uses.
I think that is a good argument for caring ketamine over other agents in the pre-hospital
setting that it just has, you know, if you have to take up one space in your small med
bag, might as well pick something that has a bunch of use cases, particularly when you
get like further and further away from like your normal urban 911 system.
If you're carrying it back into the field or in like a more austere setting, I think
that makes a lot of sense.
Yeah.
And, you know, I kind of feel that way about, you know, verse said, you know, that's not
mentioned, but, you know, my last RSI was with ketamine, but before that I had like
a run of maybe three RSIs where we used verse said, but it's not because I wanted to use
for said, it's just how the call developed.
And we just kind of pushed them over the edge with some verse said.
But before I use that drug, right, I did certain things, you know, both resuscitate and wise,
and like I said, it's how the call kind of developed like, Hey, look, they've already
got some meds in their system.
Boom.
Let's give them a splash more of her said, and we go down that pathway.
And so if that, if that kind of tells you how I feel about my loyalties to an RSI drug,
it's that I don't really have much loyalty.
I just like things that I'm familiar with.
Yeah, it makes sense.
In pre-osville, once we get in those situations, that familiarity helps drive good decision
making.
For sure.
Yeah, that's one potential downside of a time it is we basically only have one use for it.
I mean, you can use it for more things, but like in our setting in critical care transport,
we tend to pretty much only use it for RSI.
So we don't have like a wide breadth of understanding with that medication because we only ever
use it in one situation.
And then nowadays we use it in that one situation very infrequently.
Yeah.
Yeah, fully agree.
Let's talk a little bit more about the dose attenuation side of things.
Because this is something that we've talked about a little bit.
And I remember it being like a topic of discussion a while ago.
I don't know.
It's probably been like a number of years now, but there was a talk at EMTC one year
that a friend of mine like told me about and sent me some notes on just about attenuating
doses for fragile patients in general, but specifically for RSI.
And I remember like hearing a fair amount about that for like a year or two, but it
doesn't really come up in conversation anymore.
Now it seems that the focus has sort of shifted on resuscitating patients to the point where
you can use your normal doses of medications versus previously using smaller doses of those
agents.
But there is likely space for both of those ideas to coexist.
So I was just curious to know your thoughts on that.
I'm a huge fan of that.
So whenever I was flying in Houston, I spent a lot of time for the flight service I flew
was in Houston, right?
It was hospital based.
And I spent a lot of time in the OR.
We were fortunate enough to have a trauma anesthesiologist who was a former paramedic
that worked with us.
And so whenever I wanted to go to the OR, I just go to the OR.
So whenever I tell you I've spent a lot of time in the OR, man, I spent a lot of time.
And anesthesiologists are all about dose adjustment.
Anesthesiologists they rarely will ask you, okay, what's your dose range for this?
They just go a little bit of a syringe or a lot of bit of syringe, but every patient
gets their dose adjusted.
And so this made a huge push a handful of years ago, you know, adjusting doses down
to like a sliver of things or even increasing them based on certain things, right?
Burned patients is a big one.
A pregnant patient where like you might need to up your dose of something.
In emergency medicine research, that did not pan out for dose adjustment.
I will say that research for dose adjustment in our size is incredibly hard.
So it's not that it went against it, it's just it didn't prove of benefit.
As I'm sure you know, even research, you know, just behind our basic RSI stuff has
been a grind of the teeth sometimes, right?
And so from my opinion, ER physicians never really bought into that.
The only physicians that bought into that were the ones that were ED critical care or
anesthesiology critical care that intertwined with their medical.
Now one thing I do tell people is our dosages for RSI, they're huge doses.
So if your average dose of ketamine for RSI is two milligrams per kilogram, that is a
wampan dose.
That is a lot of a dose, right?
Like there are people that we just give 0.5 milligrams per kilogram to for whatever reason
or 0.3 for pain and it sends them.
And so I usually, my standard ketamine dose is about one milligram per kilogram.
That's my kind of go to.
I increase it for burns.
If they are mentally very capable prior to RSI for whatever reason, then I'll increase
it.
An example being one time in Houston, we had a guy, he was shot right here.
And Wes here is pointing to his face.
He was GCS 15.
His airway was swelling.
But I talked to him.
I told him what we were about to do and he nodded his head.
I'm going to use a bigger dose for him.
But for 80% of our RSI is pre-hosp
I'm going to use that lower dose at one milligram per kilogram and then adjust it down based
on their hemodynamics.
And you don't necessarily have to pick one or the other.
We don't have to purely go produce dose or purely push hard for resuscitation.
We need to pair our dose with our active resuscitation.
So I'll give you an example.
You get there and you have this person, hemorrhagic shock, their bleed now, their blood pressure
is terrible.
But one of the things you need to do is you need to be getting that airway and getting
off scene.
But you know you can't do it right now.
So hey, let's get the line in.
Let's push blood products hard and fast.
Will those blood products only go in so fast?
And then once they do get in, yeah, it helps the pressure.
But they have to circulate in to collect some oxygen.
And so this patient is going to be very dynamic for a while.
But you know you're going to be trending in the right direction recess wise.
You know you're going to be winning.
OK, let's go ahead and start this airway.
But maybe I don't do the full one milligram per kilogram.
Maybe I do a reduced dose of 0.5.
We do a DSI scenario, which I'll talk about here a little bit.
And let's get this airway and then be quick on our post-innovation sedation of small
amounts.
So usually whenever I do that, I'm very quick on my post-innovation sedation.
Maybe it's more ketamine.
Maybe it's a little bit of fentanyl.
All right, we do it.
Let's get this airway.
We had this very reduced dose.
But we're winning the resuscitation battle.
Now let's get some fentanyl in.
And a little bit of ketamine here.
And a little bit of fentanyl here.
And then as we're winning the resuscitation battle, we're also pushing in our sedation
meds.
So I don't necessarily play the boundary of one or the other.
I kind of just resuscitate and then add in as needed.
That's kind of how I like to do that.
I think that's a good strategy.
Because like the way, yeah, the way I've always kind of like framed it in my mind is like
when I have a range for a drug dose, I've been guilty of just picking the one that makes
the math easy so that you like draw up an even number of or like just a set straight
number of mils, like five or six mils of the drug, instead of like having to do math and
like make it more complicated.
And I think that approach is quite common versus like putting a little more forethought
into like actually calculating your dose or even like taking your dose that like makes
the number simple and then deciding if you want to give the whole thing or if it makes
sense to give less of it.
I also do the same thing when I perform DSI.
I like to give them just enough ketamine to make them compliant to my recess efforts,
whatever that may be.
Right.
So the last time I did it, I just wanted to do Vapox, a ventilator associated pre-oxination.
And so I just needed to give this guy, I gave this guy like 25 milligrams of ketamine.
He already had some alcohol on board.
And that snowed him plenty to allow me to use the ventilator for pre-oxination.
We did that.
And then I gave him, I think it was like one meg per gig of ketamine, but we even talked
about producing that dose.
It wasn't even my idea.
It was another commander's idea.
He's like, amen.
That guy took 0.25 milligrams per kilogram of ketamine really, really well.
Do we need the full thing?
And that was a conversation, right?
So I kind of, whenever I do DSI, I give them just enough of a dose to perform my recess
efforts, whatever that may be.
Like I said, that one was using the ventilator as a pre-oxination device.
So it's easy.
If I've got to do it where like, hey, I need to do like a finger thaw or a needle decompression,
or they're just kind of moving around because of head injury, I might do a little bit more.
And the 0.5 range in which it'd be 0.5 here, wait three minutes, another 0.5.
And then again, I'm pretty, I'm always pretty quick with my post-innovation.
Wait, you're telling me you're going to give ketamine to the head injury patient?
Oh yeah.
I want their head to just explode.
That's how I know that's going well.
Okay.
To derail you.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
Because I mean, that stuff comes up, right?
Because I'm sure you fly out to these rural areas and the only training they've had on
ketamine was their first training.
And that was part of it, right?
Yeah, totally.
Like that, the idea that ketamine will increase intracranial pressure and also that you have
that emergent phenomenon.
So we like didn't use it with adults for a long time.
I think that for the most part has kind of, like I don't hear, I haven't heard anyone
talk about that in a long time, but you still occasionally hear people talk about the, you
increased ICP part of things.
Yeah, very much so.
And, you know, to be honest, ketamine can, doesn't always, but can cause a surge in your
blood pressure that really you don't know how it's going to go.
And that's the scary part is when you give ketamine to a patient, is their blood pressure
going to spike to like 200, it's over 100.
Is it going to stay the same?
Is it going to drop?
Right?
It's kind of, it's very unpredictable in that moment, right?
And so I have found myself kind of criticizing people or avoiding ketamine in people that
are just uncontrollably hypertensive.
I'm not talking about the 150s.
I'm talking about people that are like 190, 200s where blood pressure is a targeted thing
in this condition, whether it be like a subarachnoid bleed or something like that.
And I'm like, okay, well, we could probably find a better, a better meds to use than,
than this ketamine here for this thing, right?
I'm playing the boundaries here of what do I want from my RSI?
You know, what's the target goal for this patient?
Makes sense.
Going back to what you were talking about earlier, when you were deciding how and when
to attenuate or diminish a dose of one of these agents, what are you basing that decision
on?
Like are there objective parameters or is it more of just this patient looks either
really sick or they're physically small in size or like something else that you're looking
for?
Like what are your, how do you make that determination?
My dose attenuation is based on several things.
First and foremost is clinical gestalt.
But just kind of your gut feeling, right?
Like are they cool, pale, diferetic?
Are they shocky?
Are they ash and gray?
Can they volume distribute this medication I'm about to give?
And then the other one is on something that we probably don't talk enough about, but
I do think is the future that EMS and emergency medicine needs to look to.
And that is clinical frailty.
Clinical frailty is something that the ICU people have been researching for a while.
They kind of have a grasp on it.
Clinical frailty is the person's ability to carry out daily tasks as relative to their
age.
So what can a normal healthy 20-year-old do?
What can a normal healthy 65-year-old do?
What can a normal healthy eight-year-old do?
And then how frail is that person from this?
Let's take the 20-year-old.
One time when I was in the OR, we had this Marine come in.
He was a Marine.
He was like 22.
He's about 6'2", about 210.
Muscle, great shape.
He was a Marine.
And but he was bleeding out.
He had a, his spleen was bleeding.
He had open tip fib.
And the anesthesiologist I was with was like, no, we're going to give him a big dose.
I was like, no, no, no, man.
Like, he's like a 92 systolic.
He's like, no, we're going to give him a big dose.
It's fine.
He'll be all right.
He can take it.
And sure enough, we gave him this big dose of propofol and we used all of our SEDS and
he took it.
But he was a healthy 22-year-old.
Now if you're a 22-year-old bed bound patient with some type of neurodegenerative disease
and you're kind of wasting, right?
And so yeah, you're 22, but you are not healthy.
You're clinically frail.
You're kind of mostly bed bound.
You struggle to get up out of bed and even feed yourself.
Maybe they can barely walk.
Those are two different 22-year-olds.
And that one that is clinically frail does not carry the physiologic reserve to handle
what we're about to do to them.
And so what I tell people is to make it easy is whatever insult you're there for, whether
it be sepsis, trauma, a stroke, airway blockage, whatever the reason why you're about to carry
out RSI.
Could this person undergo this procedure on their best day?
If that 22-year-old that's very frail and has neurodegenerative disease, if they went
in to the OR, they are not going to get a very big dose.
We were more comfortable giving a big dose to the Marine who was bleeding out from his
spleen because we knew his body could handle it.
But that's a frail person.
They can't even handle it on a good day.
That frail person goes into the OR and their dose gets attenuated down.
They stair-step them.
They'll use a lot more inhaled gas anesthetics and they expect a drop.
So that person is going to get fluid challenges beforehand.
They're going to have levofed, maybe even hanging, already going at a low dose just
because.
That's what I find myself kind of teaching the newer paramedics now.
It's about this frailty that when you look at this person on their best day, how healthy
are they before this sepsis?
How healthy are they?
Do you use that same idea solely in airway management or RSI?
Or do you also extend it into other things like let's say you have a hypertensive patient
and giving anti-pertensive or patient in pain and giving analgesia because you could take
that same idea and apply it to patients not solely for airway management?
Yeah, 100%.
I apply it.
So in your example, if we're giving analgesia or maybe we're doing a conscious sedation
or they broke a hip, I 100% apply this to it.
Now again, just because I reduced the dose doesn't mean I just give a lower dose and
stare at people.
I'll give more frequent doses.
And then I'll also apply it towards refusals.
Yeah, and I promise it, once you start kind of, whenever I take even halfway decent experienced
clinicians, introduce them to this concept of clinical frailty, and I usually spend one
shift whenever I'm precepting, I'm asking them about what's this person's frailty
level.
After that, they kind of get a good understanding of it.
So it's not a hard concept to understand.
It's just kind of getting out of the objective number framework that we get held to on a
CQI basis, right?
Totally.
The thing that I'm going to say, this plug-in hurts in people's feelings, but it shouldn't
is hop killers are great for a QAQI initiative thing.
The thought of first pass success without hypotension or hypoxia is a great QAQI measure,
and it's a great QAQI goal that I fully support.
But at the same time, we have to understand the limitations of just numbers.
And so I'll give you an example.
If we have somebody that is 92 systolic, heart rate 130s, they just got hit by a car,
bleeding out from everywhere, heart rate's 130, systolic 92, GCS of like four or five,
but the guy's like ash and gray.
The guy just looks like a tablecloth, and it looks like he's got a coat on you.
So we have that guy.
And then we have a meme all having a stroke, and her systolic is 190 systolic over like
140.
You know, rightward gaze, she's drooling on herself, you know, like a GCS of three
to four.
But if we go back to that car wreck patient, that patient gets a quick finger thaw, tourniquets,
pelvic binder, blood products, and they carry out RSI with a reduced esketamine.
And the follow up systolic on this patient are in the high 80s.
So they get, you know, the finger thaw, the tourniquets, the pelvic binder, blood products,
reduced dose of ketamine.
And this patient goes like 84 systolic, next one's 86, next one's 88.
And the patient rides in at 88 systolic all the way into the hospital.
And then we bounce over to the stroke lady, and the crew does none of those things.
The crew doesn't give any volume, no resuscitative measures, just shows up goes, all right, yeah,
I mean, she's cancer BRSI, let's do it.
And they pull the trigger for RSI.
And that lady systolic drops to 110.
Who do you think did the better job as a clinician?
Yeah, so definitely the first group, but it won't be reflected in the metrics if you're
just you're like taking away the context and you're just measuring numbers.
Yeah, so the first crew was an example of the receiving ER physician complained about
the crew based on the hot killers.
And they described this patient was about code, and they did an amazing job to resuscitate
that patient.
The second patient, the little memaw stroke was a patient I RSI.
And even though her systolic went down to 110, she went into wide complex tachycardia
and had to synchronize cardioverter out of it almost had to CPR, because I failed to
recognize the frailty.
And I did not help her neurologic status at all.
And that was a failure on my part.
But I passed the QAQI initiative.
She was never hypoxic.
She was never systolic below 90.
The other crew was a crew I debriefed.
And they did amazing.
It deserves, you know, all the the pats on the back for how they ran that resuscitation
and they paired their airway with it.
But your QAQI might not reflect that.
And it's great to have the hot killers as your QAQI goal.
I fully support that.
But there's also humans on the other side of these charts, right?
Yeah, for sure.
That's a good point.
That's my big stick on that.
Cool.
Well, let's, yeah, let's transition from airway management.
And I want to ask you another question here.
So why, why is it that finger Thor costume is the preferred chest decompression in EMS
these days?
Well, I guess to answer that question is I think mostly because it's sexy.
It's just a sexy thing to throw on social media and do.
It's good that it's becoming more prominent, kind of the same as before.
I don't see this as an either or.
I think if you have the ability to do a finger, then you also need to be proficient in your
decompression skills as well.
And it really kind of your a needle.
Yeah, your impression.
Yeah, your needle decompression, your needle decompression skills.
It actually annoys me when people are very quick to finger Thor, but then you kind of
ask them some things about the compression and they're very naive to it or just flat
out wrong to how to do it.
What's it for stuff like that?
So yeah, that's something that that's one thing I've noticed lately is that there's
a lot of I don't know what you call it, like animosity maybe against the needle decompression.
Just based on these studies about how there are potential complications if you place the
needle in the wrong spot.
So there's like a lot of resistance, the idea of teaching people how to do a needle decompression.
And the narrative is that finger Thor is a safer alternative, but it seems like a to
me it seems like a pretty easy thing to fix.
Like it's not that hard to train someone how to like find a location.
Like we train paramedics in the field to do all kinds of quite complicated things.
But for whatever reason, like the needle decompression one, it's perceived to be different in that
like it's for whatever reason not trainable.
Like we can't overcome that challenge.
Yeah, I think there's a lot of fallacies with it.
Whenever I used to teach cadaver labs, I kind of asked some people like, Hey, what are
solid indications for it?
And the absence of breath sounds alone is not a solid indication for this.
Just because there's just so many things that go along with it.
Now I can use absent breath sounds on one side as long as other parts of the story add
up.
But for the most part, like this is a hemodynamic saving procedure, not a breathing saving procedure.
If we were to mess up a needle decompression catheter on somebody that needed it, but we
just did the procedure wrong, that is one thing.
If we did the procedure wrong on somebody that never needed it, that's actually a very,
very bad thing.
And so I think a lot of it is fallacies that people have with it.
Fallacies on while we go to certain locations and we're not bearing the needle.
I still see that time and time again.
So yeah, I think the research that I've seen doesn't say that fingerthore is better than
NCD.
It just kind of says that we're very bad at NCD.
And so I mean, fingerthore cost me is a very straightforward procedure.
But again, that can still be screwed up.
Yeah, I think if you're working, if you're doing needle decompression in a system where
you have two ALS providers, I think it's reasonable to approach that the same way you would as
giving a med.
Like have somebody double check your dose, like have someone double check where you want
to go.
The other thing I was thinking of is that I think that the mindset around a fingerthore
cost me being more of a surgical procedure.
I think it makes people evaluate that they actually need it with like a little more scrutiny
than with the needle.
I think for many years the needle was kind of considered relatively benign and it's just
like simple, quick, easy to do.
Everyone with a med back now has like a 14-cage needle strapped to the front of it.
So that was like seen as a low consequence thing.
Whereas if you have a scalpel in your hand and you're like feeling your hand go through
that plural space, like into that plural space, like there is more momentum to like second
guess at like, do I actually need to do this?
Is my patient actually tensioning?
It forces you to justify that procedure a little more than the needle, which I think
potentially adds value.
That's actually a really great point.
So what you're saying is the scalpel kind of forces us to give like a tactical pause
in what we do.
Totally.
Yeah, if you think of it like as another level, the same way we would like a lot of medics,
they should put some thought into it, but not as much thought into the decision to manage
an airway as they would into the decision to a crec.
It's like a next level decision that makes you really, really need to commit to that
procedure.
You need to like assure yourself that it's justified and then see it all the way through.
Whereas if it's relatively easy to do and quick and simple, you don't necessarily put
so much thought into it.
Yeah, no, definitely.
And I guess now that you say that, I'm thinking about it, you know, we get so used to holding
the needle all the time, whether it be IV or IM shots.
For sure.
And this is just another needle.
So yeah, I think you're right.
I think that's a huge driver of it.
Yeah.
And what are your thoughts on the chest tube versus finger-thore cost?
I know where I work now, we've moved away from doing chest tubes to just doing the finger
thaw.
And I was just curious how it is down where you're at or what you think about that.
We just do the finger thaw.
When I was in Houston, we placed chest tubes.
And where I'm at here, we don't even carry them.
We just do the finger thaw.
But also kind of pre-hospital where I'm at on the ambulance.
If I'm in someone's chest, there's a lot of other things going on and I need to be
moving to a location kind of thing.
Yeah.
But I mean, chest tubes, I don't see much value in what we are decompressing the chest
for.
There's value.
So if our metal drudgers are like, hey guys, we're going to actually start putting a tube
in and securing it on scene, I'd be like, okay, it's going to kind of increase my time
on scene, but okay.
It wouldn't bother me.
But I think for what we want to decompress the chest, getting into the airway cavity,
that solves that problem.
Obviously, you know, the receiving doctors always have an opinion about that more than
I do.
Yeah, I think that's a good way to think about it in general.
The emergent life-saving intervention is to vent the chest.
So if you can do that effectively with just a finger thaw or if it's like solely air in
there and you can do it with a needle, then that's fine.
I always kind of think that the chest tube is the next step in that intervention if you
have time to help reinflate that lung.
I guess if you have ongoing bleeding, I guess that still serves a function.
Ideally, just cutting the hole in there and venting, it allows that tension physiology
to resolve.
Yeah.
I also think it depends a little bit on your context.
If you've vented the chest and now the patient is relatively stable and you have a long transport
time or you're in a more remote setting where you're going to be sitting on the patient
for a while, you might as well put a tube in and start to reinflate that lung.
You might as well work towards the next step of the process.
I think for the most part in the 911 system, it may not be necessary.
Yeah.
I could definitely see this being like in your setting if we're in our facility, like
those were the chest tube top place was they were all in our facility.
So had the equipment, could easily size it, big room.
Hey man, let's go ahead and do this now.
It's easier to do it now than try to get in the aircraft and do it or whatever.
I agree.
Yeah, I think if you have time to plan the procedure, I think it makes sense to put a
chest tube.
I think if you're doing it like an emergency and a crashing patient as part of resuscitation,
I think like a needle or a finger is totally fine.
Yeah.
And I am interested in seeing the research that will probably come out about does this
lead to more infections into the thorax and stuff like that.
Yeah.
So there was a study that I came across not too long ago and it was done by the IDF in
this conflict in Gaza.
And if I remember right, I think their protocol or their like written procedure is to do a
chest tube, but they had a number of cases where a finger thor was done instead and they
actually had worse outcomes with the finger thor.
And if I remember right, the critique was that they had more infections and that like
if you took a step back and looked at it, like it didn't like doing the down and dirty
quick procedure, like it actually resulted in more complications overall.
And the mentality was that it was like faster and quicker to do, but that wasn't necessarily
the case.
But that was like a very, yeah, I'm trying to think of like a better way to describe
this.
It didn't, it wasn't a, I think it was like an observational study.
They just like had this dataset that they saw.
It wasn't, you know, it wasn't like a, was it geared towards that?
Yeah.
It wasn't like looking forward into evaluating this problem.
It was just like based on an observation they had.
But I thought that was kind of interesting because that was the first thing I'd seen
maybe ever that was like second guessing this idea that finger thor is better in the pre-hospital
setting.
Like I think in all the time that I've been at EMS, it's like transition from chest tube
away from chest tubes to other procedures or at least towards the finger thor, maybe
not towards the needle.
But that was the first one.
The first thing I saw that kind of questioned that like, is this the best idea?
I think that falls in line with the same idea from going from a needle to a finger
thor.
Like the finger thor is seen as like a more robust procedure, like the next level intervention.
I think you can make the same argument for a finger thor versus a chest tube.
Now, if you're putting in a chest tube and leaving something in the body, you're probably
more inclined to use like a better technique in terms of like asepsis or sterility.
You probably like, whereas if you're doing your finger thor, you're probably like, oh,
you know, it's fine just to use my regular nightshower gloves and whatever.
Just take this scalpel out of a bag that has a cover on it versus like opening up a sterile
kit and prepping your field.
So yeah, I think in years to come, there will be more detail on that.
So we'll see.
Yeah, no, definitely.
And that's something that also kind of drives decision making is the risk, even if I perform
this procedure correctly, there are risks.
So even if I perform this procedure correctly and subject the patient to these risks, is
it worth it relative towards their degree of illness?
Yeah, totally.
Like deciding to intubate a 95 year old asthmatic.
Totally.
You can do that safely.
You can resuscitate and attenuate your doses, but they may never come off that ventilator.
So yeah, is it worth it?
And that's something that I think in hospital providers or good in hospital providers, I
should say, that I've observed in my time in the hospital is somebody's like critical
care docs and anesthesia will look at family and just quickly explain what this is, but
also quickly explain the likely outcome.
And it's nice to see that.
It's nice to see providers who aren't so procedure or goal driven to stop and think
about the big picture.
Because it is hard in the moment.
You have this dying patient, we want to do these procedures, airway management, get in
the chest, and then we count that checkbox as a win.
But yeah, to kind of think bigger picture there, like is this, would this really be
a win?
Yeah, I think that is something that definitely comes with clinical experience over time.
I am privileged in the fact that where I work now allows me to do both.
Both the needle and the finger.
Yeah, I think most places that can do a finger thrower also, I assume they still maintain
the ability to do a needle.
But I guess I don't know if there's programs that have totally gone away from needle decompression
and just do finger thrower cost me.
You may not have to ask around on that one and see.
Yeah, it would be interesting.
I don't want educators to go, oh, now that we can do finger, let's just not talk about
needle unless we're just bashing it.
Right?
Because sometimes educators and medical directors, when they want to push hard for something,
they bash something else.
Kind of undeservingly.
Right?
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, I mean, a great example of that is when the industry kind of shifted here in the States
to everyone, ventilating patients with the Hamilton, like all of a sudden, we had a whole
industry of like LTV and rebel haters.
Oh yes.
Even though we like flew with those machines for quite a long time.
Oh man, don't get me started on that.
You're preaching to the choir.
All of a sudden, every Joe Blow paramedic watches a few things on Instagram, has a Hamilton.
If I were to roll in, just like with an LTV or a Zoll vent, they're talking down to me.
Like, bro, I will work circles around you with whatever vent you put in my hand.
You don't even understand half what they want to tell you.
Now I say that, I say that.
Where I work now, we have the Hamilton T1s.
Yeah.
I do think they are the superior machine.
I think it's great that the price point on that machine has come down to replace the
other ones.
I think it is better.
But yeah, it's just an interesting observation how when there is something newer, all of
a sudden, you have all these reasons about why the thing you were using before is bad,
when you didn't notice before.
It would be different if that was the narrative, like, oh, these are the problems with this
machine and this is why we need a new one.
Oh, great, the new one's here.
That's not, yeah.
Yeah.
It's a whole, that's maybe a whole other discussion.
It is, it is.
But I will tell you this, an expert with a knife is always better than a novice with
a gun.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a good analogy.
But yeah, you are, you're right.
People become very classist now that they have waveforms to look at and to reference.
Well, speaking of novices with guns, why don't you tell me, Wes, about why having POCUS makes
you a better paramedic?
All right.
I love point of care ultrasound.
Okay.
Me too, just to be clear.
I'm team, I'm team ultrasound.
Good, good.
It is a non-invasive assessment tool.
Keyword being non-invasive assessment tool.
That gives us the ability to assess things that we previously have not been able to
assess.
There's three kinds of providers that will use ultrasound.
There is your brand new providers, your brand new paramedics who really aren't even good
enough at performing assessments to understand to use ultrasound.
But ultrasound can still benefit them.
When you have your very seasoned providers, your veterans, your 15-year plus guys, they're
so good at their assessments and their assessments are set in stone that they will oftentimes
tell you, an ultrasound ain't going to change my decision.
In which case I'll go, yes, it will.
It will prove to the receiving doctor or to your QAQI person what your clinical thought
process was.
Where ultrasounds really going to help people is that middle ground.
Those paramedics that are like three years in, about three to 10 years in, who now have
gotten pretty good on their assessments, this can help take their assessments to the next
level.
Yeah.
Most of my experience with ultrasound has been not in the pre-hospital setting, but
more in clinic or ambulatory care or emergency room.
When you have a little bit more time, but I found it super helpful in differentiating
abdominal pain, causes of abdominal pain when you don't have a CT scan, when you don't have
additional imaging.
And that's been super helpful for me over the last year or two.
Yeah.
Like simple things like finding polycystic kidneys and weird masses and cysts, call bladder
stones, ovarian cysts, just all kinds of stuff.
And I think that the progression from learning how to use ultrasound for a fast exam, we
always teach people when they're first learning in our setting, in the EMS setting, the progression
from going to that to doing a more general abdominal assessment is a pretty easy transition.
You're not learning a whole new skill set.
You're not changing the mode on it.
You don't really have to mess around with your depth and your settings and your contrast.
You just look in different spots.
I find that to be a really good way to take folks who are familiar with the very basics
and show them the additional capabilities of the tool.
Yeah.
Because the first learning curve that you have to overcome with ultrasound is becoming
handy with the probe, pun intended, by the way.
Yeah.
Being good with the probe is the first learning curve of any ultrasound.
So it makes sense that once you know how to do one procedure, it's easier to learn how
to do other procedures, because you know how to use the probe.
There are like two cases I hear discussed a lot for use in EMS.
One is doing fast exams, which I think is reasonable.
I think the pushback on that, and I'm curious to get your thoughts on it, is that there's
always the potential that you identify a fast as negative when it wasn't.
I think there was some hesitation to use a fast exam as a decision-making tool to bypass
facilities because what if you were overconfident in your ability and you missed free fluid
when it was there?
So I see that as a reasonable critique of pre-hospital use when there's not an adequate
measure of competency somehow.
Yeah.
And that's a real thing.
The thing about ultrasound is you use it to roll in something, not necessarily to roll
out.
I'm sure there are assessments you can use ultrasound to roll out for.
You use it in a clinic setting.
For my job and my experience, 9-1-1, EMS, I'm using ultrasound to roll in as a trigger
for something, not necessarily to roll out for things.
Yeah.
I think that's a good learning point.
Where I work, the trauma center is the next city away, so we'd have to go down to Albuquerque.
But if you had a relatively stable trauma patient, you can take them to the local hospital
in Santa Fe.
But rather than having what you would take to a level one trauma center and ruling out
abdominal bleeding and diverting to the closer hospital, using it the other way around to
say this patient would normally go to the level two here in Santa Fe, but I do see something.
So now I can rule in free fluid in the abdomen and then I divert with good reason to level
one.
I think that's a good workaround for that concern with ultrasound pre-hospital.
Yeah.
And one of the biggest, and I kind of alluded to it earlier, one of the biggest kind of
things I have trouble selling people in ultrasound is they go, yeah, but I don't know when to
use it.
When will it affect my decision making?
At what point in my assessment do I use it?
What I tell people is, okay, cool, don't necessarily use it in your initial assessment.
Do your initial assessment, especially if you're a good, fairly seasoned clinician.
You don't have to be a veteran.
Once you get a couple years under your belt, you know your initial assessment.
Bang, bang, bang.
Start getting your thought process behind you.
Start getting your differentials behind you and then use ultrasound to look at the different
things you think it could be.
So you look at ultrasound with intent rather than just blindly looking at it.
Yeah.
And especially if you have time during transport, for sure working on an ambulance, like, you
know, to scan someone's belly or to take a look at their heart, it only takes like a
minute or two, like once you, you know, get all the passes, maybe five or 10 minutes when
you're like learning like all the different views and angles and like how you want to
get your, set yourself up, but it doesn't take that long.
Like you could, you got like a 15 minute transport to the hospital and your patient,
you've already like done all the things and made your decisions.
Take the time to look around and see what you see.
Confirm those things that like, were maybes on your differential.
Yeah.
100%.
You know, in this can become a cognitive overload, especially for the people that are newer at
it.
So context is everything.
When I learned ultrasound, you know, I was flying in Houston.
There's two good, competent providers.
So one of us could be doing ultrasound.
The other one could be doing anything and everything.
If you're in a rural EMS setting, you might be the only paramedic that that's going to
see this patient and everybody else showing up might just be volunteers.
So using more than one other person, my partner rarely crossed my mind.
Right.
Yeah.
This can be a bit of a drain if you don't see a huge utility.
All right.
Like if you have this patient, you do your initial assessment.
I've got a lot of other things to do.
I got a certain IV.
I got to give them some analgesics.
I've got a color report.
I've got to do all this other assessment.
Then your ultrasound is going to be pushed down.
But if you're, you know, like right now in Austin, if I get a major call, I could be
working with a paramedic partner or an EMT.
I could have a paramedic partner show up.
I could have a PA or medical director show up.
I could have other people show up.
They can cognitively offload things for me.
I can assign the ultrasound too.
Yeah.
So therefore you'll get the ultrasound done a little bit quicker.
For sure.
Yeah.
The other use case that I see folks talk about a lot, which I really don't have much experience
with is during cardiac arrest to make a decision to terminate resuscitation.
I've used that like an ER setting a few times, but I think it matters less in a hospital
setting to do that.
I mean, it's a useful tool, right?
But in the pre-hospital setting, I think it matters a lot more because being able to terminate
resuscitation, like, frees up resources and eliminates the risk of the whole crew transporting
a patient to the hospital.
But that said, in flight, we very rarely work cardiac arrest.
It's like a bread and butter thing you do on the ground, but we don't really do that
in flight unless something goes real wrong.
So yeah, I was curious if you use it for that reason.
Yeah.
So we do use it for that reason.
We use it for that reason to obviously look for what the term now is pseudo PEA as well.
So recently, our medical directors have said, hey, like, if it's just a Sicily, you don't
necessarily have to do it per se, right?
So pseudo PEA is a big one.
Also starting to kind of understand the purpose of the arrest.
There's been a couple people that caught PEs that way.
I love using it if I'm going to pace somebody to determine capture.
That's like the number one ways to capture.
But going back to the cardiac arrest thing, it's really, really great because it's documentable.
Totally.
It is.
And in pre-hospital EMS, I don't think that average paramedic understands the power of
having something objective that's documentable.
Yeah.
And with all these devices, you can save videos.
You can capture like, you know, a five second video showing like absence of cardiac motion.
Yeah, you can't argue with that.
You see it, it's there.
I guess it's not there, right?
You know what I'm saying?
But it's very clear.
Same thing when you see some, you find like an abnormal finding on assessment.
If you see free fluid, you just take a picture of it and show it to the receiving provider
and then the trauma surgeon knows exactly where to look.
Yeah, it just really makes it clear once you know what you're looking for.
Yeah, 100%, right?
To be able to document something for QA, QI and legal purposes and then to be able to
show the next provider something is very powerful in all of healthcare.
And then again, going back to the documentable thing, sometimes before refusals, I used the
blue protocol and the lung focus.
That's my number one assessment.
If I had to tell all free hospital providers to learn one thing, well ultrasound, you would
say learn about lung assessments with ultrasound.
Yeah, and I'm not actually familiar with the blue protocol.
Yeah, superficially familiar with like doing lung ultrasound to look for like check your
fields and like the area of pneumothorax and look for like consolidations, that kind of
stuff.
I don't have like a systematic approach to it.
Yeah, so it's essentially looking at the lungs and what you're looking for is A lines,
which are good.
It tells you how much, you know, if your lungs inflating in that location.
B lines, where is it seeing some fluid?
C lines, which is where the B lines become a lot more solid.
I call them consolidation lines.
And then that drills over to hepatization, right?
Which you know, generally is pneumonia or some type of consolidation.
And then you can also see free fluid in the chest, right?
In trauma, it's hemothorax until proven otherwise.
In non trauma, medical patients, it's pleural effusion.
But anyways, you can use that to help differentiate things.
So many times we have patients who are COPD, but also FCHF, and you're trying to see which
one is causing the problem.
Am I going to go hard with the steroids?
Am I going to go hard with the nitro and CPAP?
But I've had a handful of times to where I come across a patient and they have already
had a refusal done on them two hours prior and gotten, you know, inhalers for their asthma.
And I'll take the ultrasound and tell them, like, hey, you have pneumonia.
And yes, your asthma is acting up, but it's because you have pneumonia.
Ultrasound is more sensitive and more specific towards pneumonia findings than chest x-ray.
That has been proven, right?
And so.
Yeah, with a provider who's savvy with the machine.
Correct.
But yeah, I mean, the long off sounds my number one assessment that changes my decision making
on the ambulance.
Especially for those maybe clinically frail patients we talked about.
An example being one time, this couple years ago, I had a kid, I think he was like four
years old or a little bit younger than four.
He had a trach and he's on a home vent and he had a desaturation of that.
And it just so happens the home health care nurse was there when this happened.
And she said, oh, well, you know, he just the machine got disconnected from the option.
The auction going through the machine just didn't get disconnected.
So he had desaturation of that.
And she's like, it'll be okay.
It'll be okay.
I'm like, let me evaluate this kid.
So evaluate him.
Those were diminished, you know, but clear.
But I took the lung ulcers down to him.
And sure enough, he had some hepatization down there and one of his lower lobes, right?
Now he's at increased risk for pneumonia, right?
But because he's clinically frail, it made him a very high risk refusal.
But once I kind of showed the mom that showed the home health care that like, I agree with
your desaturation event that probably was this, but we just so happened to catch some
pneumonia with it too.
Yeah.
And maybe he wouldn't have actually had a desaturation with a break in supply if he
hadn't had the pneumonia.
Exactly.
And so even if that patient didn't have pneumonia, I would still want that ultrasound on my chart
to show I did a good assessment.
Yeah.
Right.
Me doing a refusal on that clinically frail patient with and without ultrasound go two
different ways in QAQI and go two different ways in front of a lawyer.
And what are your thoughts on how to build that competency, like how to do the training
side of it?
Because I think that is something that gets a lot of discussion in EMS is like the required
training is a, like once you get the devices, the hours required to get everyone up to a
level of proficiency that is useful in the pre-aswell setting is like the number one
barrier.
Yeah.
I was curious to know like your thoughts on that opinion and also like how to overcome
that.
So the first thing you need is have a goal.
What do you want to do with ultrasound?
Do you want to do fast exams because you carry blood products?
Do you want to do the cardiac arrest thing because you've had some Lazarus events, right?
And you want that recording.
You know, I talked a lot about the lung protocol.
Obviously you have clinic stuff that you do things with.
There's vascular things, right?
If you work for a CCT program and you want to do A lines and like, hey, let's use this
to do ultrasounds.
When Raboa back in the day was becoming a thing, we started a structure to where like,
okay, we can't go from ultrasound fast exams to placing a Raboa with it.
So we're like, let's just start with ultrasound guided IVs and then ultrasound guided EJs,
right?
So we stair stepped our, ourself with the thought that we would be doing Raboa.
Spoiler, we didn't.
We got about as far as doing the ultrasound guided EJs and identifying the, the femoral
before Raboa just didn't pan out.
Yeah.
Not our fault.
But anyways, point being is we had a goal with, with it.
We had a goal.
So number one thing is you have to have a goal.
The next thing is in this where I kind of talked about one of the biggest holdups after
you give a class on it is the follow-up QAQI portion.
Right now, if, if we want to teach a new provider 12 leads, we give them a bunch of 12 leads.
We have structured 12 lead event, but then we can also follow up with them.
So many people now are competent in reading 12 leads that when a new paramedic gets released
and they do a 12 lead in the field, his follow-up on that 12 leads pretty easy.
He just shows it to his medical director, his educator or something.
So what do you think it is?
And we go, well, it could be this, this, this, and they get an answer.
With ultrasound, it's not that way.
With ultrasound, the, the QAQI and follow-up portion is extremely, extremely important.
Or else you just start looking at gray and thinking it's one thing or the other.
I'm fortunate in the fact that when I started using, I worked for a hospital based program.
I could look up what the patient CT scan was.
I could look up what the doctors ultrasound findings were.
Yeah, that's cool.
And that, and that really helped me because I did have a lot of false positives when I
started at a lot of false positives.
You mean where you thought you identified something and you didn't?
Correct, correct.
I miss, I miss identified it, right?
And so that kind of got me out of that habit as well.
So you need, before you really dive deep in ultrasound, which I encourage every department
to do by the way, it's have a plan for it and get a structured way for feedback on it
to help people learn.
After that, the training portion actually isn't super hard.
I've seen all kinds of training.
You can get with your local hospital that has like an ultrasound fellow.
When I was flying, we had a education rep from Lumify come out and teach a lot about
ultrasound.
And so that class can be done and put together fairly quickly and easily.
One of the things I'll say is try to get volunteers to come and be ultrasound because
reps, reps, reps, reps, right?
So you can get with your local community college and tell what the community college
that, Hey, this is kind of what we want to do.
We just need volunteers.
Maybe get with like a local clinic, like a family clinic, bonus points on if they take
care of OB patients to do that sounds on OB patients is a rarity, but a great one.
Everybody's anatomy is different.
Everybody's ultrasound is a little different.
So for sure.
Especially on fast exams.
So that's a big one.
The next one that's also probably going to hurt some people's feelings.
But if you talk to enough veterans, you'll see it's kind of true is lots of times these
classes are led by physicians, your ultrasound fellow or your medical director.
And that's great.
I'm not speaking negatively about physicians, but we're at a point now to where the doctors
who have gone through school over the last 10 years have only ever known ultrasound assessments.
They've never had to assess a patient without the option of an ultrasound.
And so what I mean by that is over the last 10 years, when that doctor goes to med school,
at some point in time, they came to a point in their assessment of which differential
was it.
And their attending goes, let's do an ultrasound.
And they've had that option.
So they kind of become not relatable sometimes whenever they teach ultrasound to a paramedic
or a new flight crew who have had to be good providers, good clinicians, good assessing
things without the use of ultrasound.
And now we have to integrate it in.
Do you think that's a potential downside of teaching ultrasound in initial training,
for example, in a paramedic program?
And the reason I ask is because the community college here in Santa Fe, they do ultrasound
in their paramedic school, which I think is rad.
And they do rotations with sonographers doing cardiac ultrasounds and fast exams and just
basic diagnostic stuff.
But I never really thought about the potential adverse effect of that.
Maybe it de-emphasizes good physical exam skills.
I never really considered that.
Yeah, I mean, yes, that could.
What I'm leaning towards is make sure whoever's teaching it is relatable in context.
That's actually super awesome that that paramedic school does that because the thing about ultrasound
is it's a learning curve that takes a while.
I'm sorry, but you're not going to be good in the first six months.
So the quicker you can get it, the better.
Yeah, the guy who he just recently moved on, he ran the medic program here with the EMS
training program for a while.
He introduces ultrasound during your AMP portion of paramedic school to teach anatomy.
And I thought that was really rad.
As you move into your medical and cardiac modules and you introduce fast exam and cardiac
ultrasound and that kind of stuff.
That is the perfect way.
Yeah, I never came across a program that does that before, but I thought it was pretty rad.
Yeah, that's man.
That's like the perfect way to introduce it in paramedic school.
Honestly, that is great.
Yeah, the things that we find now is you get those kind of paramedics that are five to
10 years.
They're good paramedics.
They have good assessments and they want to do this.
But these are the ones that come up to me and go, man, I just don't know like how to integrate
it into my decision making process.
I just don't know when I would use it to change my decision.
And they try and then or in the moment, they just don't think about it, right?
And it's because they learned about it, but they never learn the context by certain things.
And so that's where we start going into scenarios.
I just talked about how if I'm the only provider on scene, I can do an ultrasound, but this
patient needs all these other things from me that I'm probably not going to do an ultrasound
or I'm going to push it back.
And then some patients, right, like CH efforts where I'm trying to decide between which pathway
am I about to go down very aggressively?
I'm going to do an ultrasound, right?
Or maybe, hey, we have this patient with wheezing.
It might be cardiac wheezing, but we throw them on an ebulizer till we get some other things
situated.
OK, let me do an ultrasound.
Oh, it's not wheezing.
It's cardiac wheezes, his lungs full of fluid, pull him off an ebulizer, put him on, see that.
But knowing where to integrate ultrasound into your care is where that middle ground
paramedics start to struggle.
And that's why I say, like, if you have this class, if you have a physician who is very
relatable, then that's great, right?
Who can, who was a paramedic and can kind of work towards those questions.
But if you have like an ultrasound fellow come and teach it or maybe your medical director
is just kind of doing it, does that, be prepared for that to be a portion of your class.
Where like, hey, let's do some scenarios, even just some walkthroughs of knowing the
time and place to have that probe in your hand.
Yeah, that makes sense because I feel the same way in transport.
Like I mentioned at the beginning, like most of my experience of the last few years using
ultrasound has been not in transport.
But I like, I have my own device that I like bring with me flying that like oftentimes,
like I wouldn't delay to do this thing because we already have like a treatment in place
and I'm not necessarily, you know, like in our sitting, like most of the diagnostics
already done, so it would just be like confirmatory.
So I oftentimes like just don't use it.
But it would be different if I was like working emergency, like in a 911 truck.
I think it would be different to like, yeah, to make those decisions without like reading
a CT scan report or a test expert or whatever.
Yeah.
And you know, one of my biggest selling points is like what you say is confirmatory.
You know, pre-hospital medicine struggles with that more than what they know is being
a trusted source of an evaluation.
For sure.
You know, yeah, I think, I think it's the future.
I think the way that college by you is doing it is immaculate.
I've tried to get our in-house permit program to do something like that.
But until national registry changes their standards and stuff for it, most programs kind of won't.
Yeah, I mean, it's tough though, because like whenever you introduce a new thing into a training
program, you invariably have to like make space for it.
So I can see the resistance, especially now, I like the devices are expensive and not that
many people have them.
But I think, yeah, in the next few years, I think the price point on devices in the
pre-hospital setting or just like for like the container to a smartphone or tablet will
come down significantly.
Like they're already fairly cheap.
Like you couldn't buy a secondhand butterfly on eBay for less than a thousand bucks now,
which is pretty rad.
Cool.
All right.
So let's do a quick recap.
We talked about why ketamine is so great.
We talked about why figured the words are so great.
We talked about why focus is great.
Anything else that we need to discuss before I let you go?
Oh, nothing right now.
I think we've talked to the moon and back about all the problems in EMS and why ketamine
can solve them.
Yeah.
We just kind of said this out to the citizens and then our industry will be fixed.
I know, right.
Just if you have a paramedic with ketamine in one hand and a butterfly ultrasound in
the other.
Exactly.
That guy's going to do something for you.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
Just before we hop off here, I just want to give a shout out to my friend, Josh Pitman
and his buddy, Kevin Pons.
They're the ones who put the music together for all of this.
Catch you next time.